[Music]
Principles of Success
30 Minutes 8 Episodes Ultra-Short Adventure
episode 1 Mannequin to Adventure I Want to Refuse
Before I Start I
have Limited Knowledge of What I Need to Know
I Experience In Life  Any success you have depends on knowing how to deal with ignorance rather than what I know. What I
should do is be a little adventurous to teach others,
but I'm not hesitant to succeed to me  Because I believe that the principles that led to these eight people are also beneficial in achieving their goals
a I have learned
how to succeed rather than find a way
for me to be more successful now.  It's much more important to tell people that it's
up to you what to do with that principle.
You have to be an independent thinker. You can come up with your own principles based on your own values
.  Because you are the only one I want to say is
the most basic principle of business law: you have to think for yourself what is true
So let's get started I'm a principle to me early in life
Is the wisest way to deal with recurring events under similar circumstances to the principles that I realized I needed.
In particular, I intend
to influence all the behaviors that humans choose
and share
with you the most important and inclusive principles of life for me.
The principles of my life are simple
and unfinished, but I
'm still struggling and failing while chasing the best decisions on the site.  I'm learning new principles
This is the reality First song guards I had to move away from the habits I took for granted I
mean I needed an environment to think for myself If you don't want to leave your life to others
you're yourself
You have to decide what to do on your own and you have to have the courage to do so
But I didn't even know it at first and learned from my own adventures once
I look back on my own journey and time carries us  The
reality of being forced to make a decision that turns out to be like a river flows toward waiting  We can't avoid that reality unless we stop this flow,
but we can only approach it in the best possible way
. You're forced to make countless decisions outside the game.  Deaf
The quality of your decisions determines the quality of your life The
most valuable lesson I have made as a result of reflecting on the mistakes I made in trying to help shape my principles so that I do not repeat the same mistakes along the journey of life.  With
that principle I was able to achieve great success and rewarding work that was evaluated by common standards by children from the most mediocre middle class families from the out-of-the-box land.
Valuable relationships are also other
things
Its value is not a ratio of my mundane success I'm often asked from scratch about the facility, but I'm
sure it's not because I was a special person, etc.
It's a special approach to life  I believe it's a result and it works for everyone. It
starts with accepting reality and dealing with it. In
Episode 2, it's your most important decision to unravel it and choose the path your life will take:
In
my case, I sought a life that I didn't have. I
was afraid of a life that was more boring and rut than moving by.
I was able to put my decision on
what I wanted to do. Since I was a child, I desperately chased what I wanted
and bumped into it
.  I learned something and grew up and the
result was less bumpy
. After repeating this over and over again,
I became able to love this process, including the bumper part.
Faced with and learned how to deal with it,
that experience has imbued me with another basic principle.
That's what reality
means when I use the word Shinji, which is an essential foundation for producing good results.  It's
just a mechanism for the world to move. I believe that human beings are born given the laws of reality.
I don't imagine, but human beings use it as the driving force of their evolution to achieve their goals.
That Satoshi turned me into
a surrealist, that is, reality, not my ideal reality  I think I'm
a skeptic
who specifies the realization of my dreams when I call myself a surrealist
.  There are people
It's definitely not a different dream Life is boring, but
I just want to say that surrealism is the best way for people to choose and realize their
dreams and have big dreams
and reality  Accept
and make a lot of decisions and
you get a successful life
[Music]
This formula is the truth that applies to everyone
So what exactly is a successful life? It's what each of us thinks and defines for ourselves.  No
matter what you wish to be the ruler of the universe, longing for life in the palm trees and whatever else
I wish,
each of us has our own values  Choose goals based on
and master the best way to achieve them, but we all need
to be aware of a decision-making approach that works especially when we encounter problems, mistakes and weaknesses that stand in our way.
I have to accept all
my reality I had a lot of pain every time I encountered such a painful reality at first, which was a harsh reality that I didn't want,
but that pain was just a matter of how to hold my heart.  I learned that changing the way I look at things can change everything,
and the problems that come to me seem like puzzles that reward respondents.
Dealing with current problems
From home and in the future to deal with similar problems
I also learned how
to take the reward of the principle of
= When it
comes to progress, it was the tree that played an indispensable role for me to maintain this attitude. I am full
of joy from the rewards of cooling the ball, accepting my reality, and working on
it.  The
pain has disappeared. Each of us has
a special thinking ability to think theoretically about ourselves and its environment and to move toward personal evolution.
In episode 3, which is involved in one step,
we will see how to use it.
Having talked about the importance of scrutinizing it after
testing, I was able to discover the principles that usually protect me from making the same mistakes over and over again in the future through these steps.
I realized that there are only five steps in the process of success. Step 1 is
to know your goals and chase them.
The best for you depends on your humanity,
so you have to understand yourself well.  And
the step you need to know what you want to achieve in your life is to run into problems that stand on your way to your goals
.
These problems are generally painful and can ruin yourself if mishandled.
In order to evolve, you must recognize the problem and never pretend to see it. In
step 3, diagnose the problem of the gorilla and find out the root cause. Do not
jump over here and go to the solution. What is the symptom?  I
want you to take a step back and make it in-house so that you can clearly identify what is the root of the disease. In
step 4, make a plan to eliminate
the problem.
Carrying out the plan you made with steps A
successful life is made by taking these five steps over and over again while doing what you need to do to achieve your goals.
This is your personality.  Is an evolving process and it can be anywhere.
This is a very natural law. I want you to think of something.
Someone who knows some organization or someone
.
Is an adaptation or a pross of either world
. It consists of exactly the five steps I described as an image,
and if you dry the process painfully for a while, your level of success will naturally rise to a higher level.
Submitted even when I cleared relatively well Nunokawa did not mitigate
because I am improving
-/-because the confusion that awaits me is greater Each
person has different strengths and weaknesses,
so all five steps are dexterous  There are only a limited number of people who can handle it.
If you don't see this reality, you will grow taller without knowing what you are doing.
And the higher the price, the greater the impact when it falls.
Sometimes I meet a miserable situation  Depending on how we deal with it,
it can be devastating and, conversely, the
sexual roots rehashed. 1982 I encountered this kind of event. In Episode 4
, I
want to tell you what happened to me.  And the action I took there is that when a person encounters a setback, the whole body stops walking
. Whether to get out of that setback and continue moving forward or fall into a negative spiral
is an objective failure to turn the loop again.  A tragedy
that happened to me in 1982, depending on whether I had it or not,
it was when I poured all my fortune into the Pope, who had never
caused it.
1979  From to 1982 the world economy and markets
and one serious turmoil in my body struck
I called the US economy on the road to catastrophe with the world economy closely linked to it.
The pros and cons were clearly divided, and I took a big risk as a public public
and made a mistake. After passing through Tokyo, the
stock market
began to show strong momentum, and it continued for 18 years.
And the U.S. economy enjoyed the greatest growth period in its history.
This experience has given me the shock of a strong blow to my head with a baseball bat.
And one
employee was me, and
I had to borrow $ 4,000 from my father to pay,
but it was harder to
dismiss the people I had cherished until then.  I was wondering if I should give up my dream of becoming a person and live a dark life while working as a hired person for a job that requires me to go to work and a memorial service every day.
I knew that it would reduce my happiness.
Big mistakes, especially as a public person, make people
painfully humble.  I'm still hurt and embarrassed
.
I was more likely to work hard than to make a wrong decision, but one mistake
made me mess up everything.
Thinking hard about the relationship of
ranks and how to deal with them, but without taking unacceptable risks to me, the
pile I want  I couldn't imagine a way to
expect  You may suffer
or your career may turn white
Life is over and you may think that there is no way to go,
but the example goes by I affirm that the
best way is before you  You
have to look back at the trials and accept the reality to find it, probably you haven't seen it yet. In Episode 5
, I want to talk about how that awareness turned me into a stack of reality.
And the best
way to do it with reality often happens to be incomprehensible to us. Life is difficult and complicated,
and I often feel that I ca
n't swallow it all at once.  I was guided to look back, and at the same time I began to
think about nature in search of support for the truth, and I was
so indulged in the mechanics of things
that I was able to correctly identify me and my situation.
With the big bang I just learned, everything is imagined from the law of the universe and begins to evolve from there
, interacting like a permanent motion machine and fusing all the particles and fragments in it
to form an opportunity to continue for a certain period of 6  The split teak
and then enter the process of a from here to merge into a new machine
. Everything I understand is an opportunity.
The structure and evolution of the galaxy and the formation of our solar system are
medium terrain and  The nature of the ecosystem, our economy, the market, and each of us, each of us is a
machine that is composed of various different opportunities. The opportunity of the circulation type. The machine of the
nervous system.
And feelings and other elements of unique qualities
and I'm deciding what to do during the 1ns when I realize I'm just one fine grain.
It may sound like a philosophical thing, but I thought it was very practical
because it taught me how to better interact with reality,
for example, almost everything subtly changed shape and
many times.  Obviously I didn't bring a short cycle while I noticed it was happening repeatedly
Some things are easy to deal with because they are easy to deal with, for example, some things happen in a one-day cycle,
while others rarely happen and we do not experience them in our lifetime,
so the shock we receive when that happens is great, for example, once every 100 years.
There are also events that happen for the first time, such as big earthquakes,
for example,
most people mistakenly treat these situations as something special, such as during delivery in English,
and try to get out of it.  I deal with it without having the perspectives and principles that I should have. I noticed that if we do not
see such events as transient,
we can see each one as a disaster and
biologists can deal with animals.  I can
quickly identify the child and extract the principles for correct handling
while imitating the approach I take, and I dominate the mechanism because I was able to understand how these happenings recur in exactly the same way
.
I was able to find a clearer causal relationship,
which allowed me to come up with better principles that can be explained in words and algorithms.
I'm expecting it, but it's basically a big mistake. I'm expecting it because it's been
influenced by recent things and it's biased because it hasn't happened for a long time,
or
it's an event mistake that I've never experienced in my life.
Repeatedly standing in that childhood and looking back, what I had overlooked when I misread the arrival of the Great Depression
was actually hidden in a pattern of history,
from which I realized that I knew about that pattern.  When I found a new one and used
it as a food for making better decisions in the future, and when I returned to my own trials considering the balance between risk and return,
I realized that the two were naturally linked.
If you want to get more harvest from, you have to take bigger risks
And knowing how to properly balance risk and eating is the essence of life's best
Imagine yourself being forced to make choices  Let's be content with the status quo,
but live a boring life, or take a risk and live a wonderful life as a reward for running through a dangerous jungle
. I'm forced to make this choice in terms of sound quality.  The answer is
It's fixed,
but the road isn't smooth sailing Two big barriers common to all humanity
have been waiting for me In Episode 6, I'll share the irreplaceable techniques I've learned about how to overcome
them.  I don't know which is the best way for you because I
don't know how important it is for you to achieve a feat compared to avoiding the pain you have to experience to get it.
I
want to talk about the courage I've come to before It's the courage that each of us should seek out on our own will
After making a blunder in the reading of the Great Depression Who I was at a turning point in my life
If I had chosen a mediocre job and a stable route
there, I would have lived a completely different life, but
I paid the rent, had meals on the table, and raised children as much as I could.  The only way to choose is
to take the risk of hitting the jungle in search of the best possible life I failed to read the Great Depression
I now have a healthy fear of mistakes
I just needed  It came to have a deep humanity, but
at the same time it didn't prevent me from actively pursuing what I wanted. In
aiming for success, I needed to see more than I had seen on my own.
However, on the
way to that, the two barriers of consumption, the ego and the blind spot, which the big and small animals blocked the way to stand in common with everyone,
are caused by the way our brain works.
Let's first look at the ego barrier.  What I mean
is your English barrier is the part of your brain
that prevents you from objectively recognizing the weaknesses of the three heads.
If you have that awareness, how should you deal with your weaknesses?  It turns out that
your most two-tiered desire is in the area of your brain that controls your emotions and is se
arated from your higher dimensional consciousness, so you want to think of yourself as a fallen person, the t
uth is.  Prefer to believe in one's thoughts without proper stress testing because it is more important than the desire to see something,
especially because our tendency is to turn away from mistakes and weaknesses.
If you do, you will instinctively react as if you were attacking. Listening to
the opinions of others Home
is more sensible but angry  We lose our reason because we are dominated by ourselves. Thus,
our judgment is weakened,
our chances of learning are reduced, and our potential is deprived.
The second is the obstacle of
blind spots.  It appears when you are overwhelmed with the confidence that you know everything, but it is
a clear fact that no one can see the full reality on their own.
Naturally, one correctly evaluates what one does not see.  Just as there are various different fields in the pulsation of listening to the singing sound that cannot be done,
the movement of judging and understanding things
can be further classified.
For example
, I am good at seeing things musically.  Some people are good at discerning details. Some people are
linear thinking. Some people think about things from seven people. Some people are
creative but lack honesty. Some people are sincere but lack creativity.  Because there are
individual differences in the pathways of the brain, which is ten people and ten colors, there are also individual differences in the way of
recognizing the world around you.  The weaknesses of the human being can no longer be grasped
and shattered into fine dust.
There is no other way but to continue or change. According to Aristotelis, tragedy is a
tragic result of a fatal
defect in one human being.  In
my opinion, these two obstacles are the main factors that hinder our path and make good decisions.
I needed to worry about misunderstandings.  It gave me a thorough listening attitude
.
It changed everything. I
can't stand to take more damage by taking
risks and miss great results by not taking risks.
I needed a successful approach that would only put me in the updraft without dropping me into the abyss
. When I learned of its existence, it became my ultimate goal.
But to get there, I
had to trade the joy of justifying myself for the joy of learning the truth.
Their conclusions driven to find out
are not a problem, I just wanted to see things from their point of view and I wanted them to see my four
things so actively with each other  To be able to argue and reveal the truth In other
words, I could say that I was
most expecting a counterargument from them
. I was looking at things only from my
own point of view.  What changed to
what I saw was that I was watching things in black and white, but it was a change that I started to see. It
was the moment when the world was lit. At
this time, I was to get out of the jungle of my life.  I realized that the best way is to walk with someone who has insights that are different from
you. Remember the five steps I mentioned earlier,
but again, there are big individual differences in our brain pathways.
Therefore, some people may have a hard time taking five steps, but there is no need to challenge it alone. People
who are good at what they are not good at and have
cognitive ability and brain pathways that produce it.  You can ask for help
Hey, who are you? Cut off your obsession with trying to get the right answer on
your own, and use your fear of making mistakes to just prepare to open up to a different opinion.
It's good. By
doing so, you can find risks and opportunities that you would have missed if you were alone
.  The
chances of me making the best decision within the limits of what I am allowed have increased dramatically.
Thus I have risen to higher heights and the trials that await me have scaled up.
If I only wanted to do what I thought was the best, but now I'm looking for the strongest and most independent thinker I can, and it's still the
same It's nothing more than sharing a mission with different people
With people who can talk in a straightforward and honest way, with
this approach I created a company of unique idea elites,
where they operate in a unique way to create unique successes
Everyone chooses in the idea elite  Each person who can meet the best thinks for himself
and then
tries to run away from each other while aiming for the best
. Just because not all opinions are worth one,
we start with good ideas from bad ones.  I needed the power to be more divided, so
I sought the way to the best decision.
We needed a sense of trust that respects people's opinions,
but we want to touch on that in the next work-principal slowdown.
There are many great opportunities and dangerous risks you haven't seen at this time.
If you can take off the colored glasses that arise from ego and blind spots and see the chances and lists, you
can deal with them more effectively, but
if you practice what you can master this ability, you  Will basically support your life
1 In
episode 8 you can finish your journey with me and start your own journey
I am as I am until now, that is, myself with problems, failures, weaknesses, etc.
I've talked about how to deal with and how I've met people who are better than me and have surrounded me and
challenged me. This
was certainly the most effective way to make the best decisions I've discovered.
But this approach made me a successful person, and
with
further success I was able to meet extraordinary successful people and learn and know their way of thinking
and their journey is to me
You may not know that they are keeping it, but they are all struggling to cover the
risks and opportunities that they are likely to overlook with their weaknesses.
As time goes on,
I often find that a person's most prominent strengths are essentially linked to their most prominent beginnings, and that
desperate efforts to do great things are destined to plunge a person into a valley of pain.
It's just one act of a book on the process of success.
That setback is sifting through those who are trying you. We'll
scrutinize the cause of the setback, learn lessons from it, and move forward toward your goals.  Some people decide
that the
game isn't right for them and leave halfway through.
I realized that success isn't about whether or not a person achieves that goal.
When we reached a higher level of new success,
the satisfaction was rarely continued by two people. What we strive for
is nothing more than food. Desperately trying to get it.  By struggling we
evolve and aim to evolve with others The
struggle is the reward
I no longer wanted to cross the jungle
Instead, I argued with the big guys along the way
and sought a much larger trial than I could travel in cooperation with each other. Eventually,
the success of that mission and the delivery of my companions gave me my own success.
Masa became important to put in, and I started to go beyond my own ally and in the meantime
started looking for a way for people to succeed without me.
I'm still struggling, and
each person has a different purpose and struggle, but the process continues until I choose to give up on the way
or die and step into a larger evolutionary story.
Just as all machines repeat operation and regeneration in parallel with the passage of time When a machine
breaks, the parts used
there return to the system again as parts of a new machine that evolves through statistics.
We are saddened by this reality because we have a stronger attachment to machines than we do,
but we want you to have a higher level of bird's-eye view. How wonderful it is to worship the work of more advanced machines.
You
have to get used to and decide for yourself how you evolve. Forget who taught you
the principles. Evaluate if our principles work for you and meet your own needs.
It's you who decide what to do with that principle as well as all life decisions
I just want you to have the courage to struggle well
Thank you and where  Let's meet
me